for fun conversations right I thought we
should end today upbeat what's going on
reject nation its Greg Alba here
with me today is best friend John we
aren't getting comfortable with each
other you're no longer comedian John
Moses maybe we should go for a three
bedroom apartment I'll raise your
daughter for you speaking of daughters 5
scariest extreme for camp host I need
explaining the top five unknowns
fantastic channeling like in 2014 a
series of photos showing a naked
strangled woman were posted on a 4chan
Jesus was released just hours after the
woman's body had been reported to police
the victim was a thirty year old mother
of four named Amber Shaw and was found
dead in her apartment located in
Washington the lead suspect in this case
was a man named a it was from Warrington
according to the photos as well as a
police report when David posted the
photos to forge in he will check the
news for Port Orchard Washington in a
few hours her son will be home from
school soon you will find her than to
call the cops
I just wanted to upload these photos
before they find me I bought a BB gun
that looks realistic enough when they
come for me I'll pull it and it'll be
suicide by God I understand the doubts
but just check videos you have to lose
my phone for now according to the
official press release David's wishes
came true her body was in fact
discovered by an undisclosed family
member and reported to police
immediately Jesus allegedly after the
murder took place
David fled in the victim's car in just
19 hours later her car was found and
David surrendered without resistance
he was then charged with first-degree
murder
it's believed that the two individuals
needs some sort of a romantic
relationship which was ultimately broken
off this fishing would constantly to
lash out while severely intoxicated
resulting in the murder though this is
yet to be confirmed okay in April of
2013 an anonymous user posted two
fortune
detailing plans of committing a mass
shooting at a mall near Christiansburg
Virginia the user uploaded a series of
photos to the be forum detailing his
plans as well as stating that he was a
student from a local Community College
he then uploaded again the later that
afternoon just minutes before the
shooting took place simply stating it's
time to enter New River Valley Mall and
begin shooting at random individuals
with the shotgun though things didn't go
as planned
and he managed to fire just a handful of
rounds before police arrived at the
scene taking him into custody thankfully
no one was killed during this event and
only two people were injured both of
whom recover the shooter named Emil
McGuinness was the victim of a
troublesome childhood plagued with
mental issues and apparently have
attempted to commit suicide when he was
just 15 then attempted two additional
times after that and even science'
father if he stated that he feared the
worst that could happen for Neal was
that he would eventually succeed in
killing himself and certainly didn't
believe he would resort to attempting to
kill others according to Neal one of his
reasons for committing the shootings was
to raise awareness for gun control and
for better security in schools while his
family weren't heavily to get Neal
admitted to a mental health facility
rather than prison
though these attempts were ultimately
paid Neal was just 18 years old at the
time of the shooting it was 38 years in
prison
oh that's some fresh Prison me 38 years
for killing in 2010 a disturbing video
showing a young woman throwing puppies
into a river oh my god
sending users into a frenzy attempting
to track the woman down the video which
we can by no means show Clips out was
posted in a 4chan before but the caption
find this dumb girl and throw her into a
river unfortunate search efforts like
fortunately someone whose
you can't Joey gallon wish the video is
uploading too they found his hometown as
well as his Facebook account they used
this info to then track down two
separate Facebook accounts owned by
women either of which could have been
the perpetrator though as 4chan is well
known for they simply began harassing
both of the women rather than taking the
time to figure out which one was at
fault though they did eventually find
out which girl it was and within just a
few hours she had been tracked out to
Bosnia and was arrested by police a
short while later the original police
report has since been removed from
public access online but judging by the
portions of the report that had been
uploaded by foreign media outlets police
claimed to have found and questioned the
girl apparently she believed that
throwing the winner of puppies into the
river would have been the most humane
way to kill them though it's unsure why
she wanted to kill them in the first
place doesn't appear as though any
charges were placed against the girl but
she was forced to give a public abouts
crazy and get away with that that's
crazy
number two a 4chan user in 2012 posted
to the site informing users of a
seemingly live grenade that he had found
while surging through his deceased
father's belongings he wasn't sure what
to do with the grenade or who to take it
to so rather than seeking a professional
he simply asked users what he should do
it
after posting numerous photos to a
device supposed to terrifying images of
one hand another grenade even showing
himself running it over with his car at
one point users continued to press him
on asking him to do more and more
ridiculous oh my gosh a man posted a
photo of himself hovering the grenade
over a toilet asking if he should drop
it in and flash but this ended up being
the final post he'd ever made just a day
or so later a Guatemalan news outlet
released the story of a man who had
blown himself up with a hand grenade
while in his bathroom why would you use
this be quick to look at this the
original posters IP address was indeed
from Guatemala what some to me
certainly does seem like Opie was in
fact killed by his own negligence an
idiot Emily Irene sander was an eighteen
year old student at Butler Community
College and Eldorado Texas
Emily suddenly went missing on November
23rd 2007 it was found dead six days
later oh I thought they're gonna lose
now that guy's sander and an unknown man
were seen leaving a bar in East Eldorado
on November 23rd 2007 sport this man was
later identified as 24 year-old Israel
marilla's it was the last person to see
Emily alive later blood was discovered
in Marella's motel room next to her to
an Italian restaurant where he worked as
a waiter Emily's car was found still
parked at the bar the rental car
Bareilles was driving was found
abandoned later that month in Vernon
Texas where he claims to have had
relatives
six days after Emily's disappearance on
November 29th her body was found 50
miles east of El Dorado police initially
refused to describe the condition of her
body though it was later revealed that
she'd been stabbed multiple times and
strangled with a telephone cord local
police Falmer Ellis and Mexico on
December 19 where he was arrested and
charged with capital murder rape and
sodomy when captured Morales is found to
be with his 16 year old pregnant
girlfriend Victoria Martins according to
Sandy Martin's the mother of Victoria
Martins her daughter had called her on
November 24th to tell her that Morales
had been involved in an altercation with
another man who attended to Robyn Cindy
also claimed to received a text message
from her daughter days after the couple
floods saying that she quote had a lot
to tell her mother leader the mother
said that she believed her daughter
thought the trip to Mexico was a
vacation
Victoria later called home and was
picked up at the border and no charges
were filed against her because Morales
suspected of impregnating Martins he was
also charged with aggravated indecent
liberties with a child Marella says
trial was held from February an to 12 in
2010 he was convicted of rape and
capital murder though the aggravated
sodomy charge was combined as part of
the capital murder charge on March 31st
2010 he was sentenced to life in prison
without the possibility
of parole marilla's currently resides in
Hutchinson Correctional Facility in
Atchison Kansas yay guys so much for
watching if you like this video be sure
to click that like button also don't
forget to subscribe and click that
notification hit that like button
all the time so might as well let's talk
about this guy alright yeah the for the
first I think he could have possibly
been a better Joker than Jared Leto just
based on his head like he's got a great
Joker ahead but ladies if you're dating
a guy who has and I'm you know have
facial hair so does great but if you're
dating a guy that has his facial hair on
his chin fashioned into a penis yeah
maybe you shouldn't pursue a
relationship it's like Kevin Federline
yeah yeah yeah there's got the stain and
goatee that's that there is definitely a
breed of guys I love when they have
these like these like happy photos they
throw these stories know him in there
with the Santa hat on yeah yeah the
Santa hat him looking devilish like a
grandmother that said he was such a nice
boy is not going to convince anybody
yeah like he was always we'd be able to
know you look at this photo you're like
no way no everyone he was born in your
purse this guy with the shooting people
at the mall so what do they do the
fortune they like like giving like heads
ups like hey I'm gonna do this I guess
so what is this 4chan site they're just
so desperate for attention can I promote
my youtube videos on there I think I've
had some stuff on 4chan this is actually
like a good video as far as like mass
shootings are concerned because nobody
was killed he only shot two people yeah
before he was stopped so I guess there's
a bit of a positive on this I mean
that's an extreme way to get a message
across
oh yeah he's like I just wanted to tell
people about gun safety yeah look what I
can do if I have a
they're people oh Jesus man that's
terrible 18 years old only 38 years in
prison yeah well you would think that it
would be extended yeah 38 years I
haven't think that was we like life in
prison
oh if you're 18 I am sure you know those
38 years at least the first five or six
and we're gonna be in dog years yeah he
is gonna be getting passed around
good for him yeah my preferred you know
I always thought about that what if
that's what you wanted yeah like that
movie with William H Macy brownie pup
you know I could I could probably see
videos of like a human being getting
killed but I'd want to mm-hmm
but I could probably watch that I mean
like drowning puppies that's something I
just can't do I can't handle that you
seem like you're okay with that
I'll say you're okay dog person what the
hell was the point of it she never
explains why she's doing it she can't
get your hands on babies I don't know
did you see that the head of Steven
Seagal movie where he finally gets the
puppy guy at the end he's like throwing
puppies out in like garbage bags
oh I did not see this it was such a
small thinking Seagal movie it was like
at the beginning of the movie if you're
not gonna go to jail at least a good
pounding wood should be you know up for
that that's you know the quality being
what it is I'd rather see a baby thrown
in a river
Jesus I got cat I got trouble for saying
I'm a cat guy and ready you're ready for
babies to get around oh yeah I got my
sister a dog okay yeah you have a baby
sorry no you don't have a dog don't
drown babies or puppies or puppies cats
are okay my favorite story was the idiot
the gurney what a waste of your only
inheritance like I found this thing that
my father had who live 90 years without
managing to blow himself up my favorite
thing is there are people on the
internet on this porch and cider like
try this out
and survive this one running over the
grenade with his car yeah and in the
next day they're like who would he
finally does die they're like oh that's
a load up in a toilet oh geez what a way
to go
every a worse way to go that are sex
yeah I'll take dying and dine at toilet
over sex no I'll take dying in the
middle of sex then then wonder if
there's anybody else that got caught up
in that like if somebody was upstairs
taking a [ __ ] they'll say that is really
a weapon to kind of yeah yeah that was
bomb but still a grenade why would you
do that well life imitates art there was
an influential movie you never know with
these videos sometimes you can get a
good discussion going and sometimes
you're like you can't you can't make
life funnier but you can't make light
about somebody's story especially in
this like age of Instagram everything
sometimes you got to think about what
pictures you're taking because if you do
die they might show you in like a female
sexy Halloween coffee the glamour shot
was my era so there's all these nice
pictures they had they had this is
shuffle demons in let's turn the the
photo where she was hot and sexy yeah so
you'll really miss her right now that's
a real tragedy now it's a real chore oh
she was so hot this is one happy
Halloween I'm ready to cover today so
we're gonna have a really fun discussion
about real-life tragedies yeah just for
you guys
you requested it be happy you're still
alive just be happy you're still alive
amen to that
and don't experiment with grenades c4 is
one thing but the grenades is a whole
other story much harder to control
landmines too you can experiment with
landmines explosive diarrhea that's a
batteries Ronnie yeah subscribe
yep John Moses on Twitter at John Moses
and Facebook and Instagram act comedian
John Moses follow him there and
subscribe to top five unknowns
take care of folks